tonight I have the honor of presenting
an Academy Award to a national treasure
the incomparable Angela Basset in case
you all didn't
know I was blessed to work with Angela
in two beloved films How Stella Got Her
Groove Back and boys in the
hood in How Stella Got Her Groove Back
Angela played the title role and I
played her younger sister which was the
easiest role I could imagine because
Angela really is a sister to me
truly my sister and I first cross paths
on a little show called
227 you didn't know I was going to bring
that one out on you
right only to later have our coming out
party in the same film John Singleton's
boys in the hood